chchoix engendre Justin Trudeau
ququi défend les intérêtsts des
ririches des investisseurs ou de
vovoter pour les néo démocrate
etet... pour les deux médecins
- - est-ce que c'est vraiment
efefficace?
- - Eh bien non, l'impact est
mamarginal et de coût t duré.
AÀ Toronto l'achat d'un propriéé
papar les étrarangers déjà e en
vivigueur en AOC à V Vancouver s
dede 20 %. Elle a été adoptée en
202011 mais moins d'un an plus
tatard les faits s'est estompé.e
nonombre de transactions est
sesensiblement revenu au même
niniveau et son attaque. Selon
l'l'analyse de la chambre
imimmobilièrere de la Colombie-
BrBritannique. L'incidence de la
tataxe est difficile à évavaluer
paparce que plusieurs variantes
prprendre de compte. Je la suisà
ccôtété de. Le prix moyen du
prpropriétaire de 1 075 000 $
VaVancouver et de 1 160 000 $
ToToronto.
- - On va interdire étrangers Da
SeSena maisoson au Canada surtot
s's'il n'ont pas l'intention de
vivivre au pays.
- - La réalité c'est que les
prpropriétaires étrangers ne sot
papas que ça. Ils détiennent un
pepeu plus de 4 % des propriétéà
VaVancouver de moins de 3 % à
ToToronto. Pour mettre fin à laa
crise il faut souligner que la
nénéodémocrate propose aussi la
coconstruction de 500 000
lologements sociaux sur 10 ans e